everyone will converge in the middle of  the map and it will a be without any  modification here now Salo draft are  already and it looks like throwing down  some foundations over there definitely  going to be making pikes  and most likely crossbows and maybe even  guns oh no what are they going to be  able to do they're taking out all the  time hooking it like my mama was chased  me when I was a kid it just straight of  it I see your hand raise you with dragon  gone from an underdog to back home our  tribe eliminated it's a guess and he's  going in for it yeah he doesn't legend I  cannot believe what I'm seeing  ruins gonna be a lot of man alive oh my  god what is going on here  like they're stabbing each other this is  Sabbath they are all going in good at  playing the man until someone this isn't  your normal Battle Royale  no this is the survival bit  clothes things